the initiative seeks to remove
marijuana from the federal list of
controlled substances and would also give
banks access to businesses
related to the
marijuana trade currently businesses in
states that have legalized the sale of
marijuana work mainly
with cash the proposal of more
would tax irregular and marijuana sales
to good news my
way senator chuck schumer said he will
use his influence as the leader of
the democrats to make this
proposal a priority in congress
summers says
federal marijuana laws are
outdated  and affect
minorities unequally the
Democratic lawmakers who introduced the
proposal also want
people to be able to get rid of
non-violent criminal records
related to marijuana possession
and also allow
reduced sentences for people
imprisoned for the same reason the
taxes generated  for the sale of  e
marijuana would be
used in part to help
African-American Hispanics and other
minorities, for example, with subsidies so
that these people can open businesses
related to the
marijuana trade reporting in washington
alexandra limón